esta actividad global estuvo muy marcada
también en el área deportiva está con
nosotros en el estudio el mar esa de la
redacción de deportes de france 24 es
una de las áreas que se ha visto
impactada por este conflicto el mar
buenas noches gracias por acompañarnos y
cuál ha sido entonces hasta el momento
las reacciones que ha habido allí y las
consecuencias que tiene esta incursión
militar para el sector deportivo bueno
vamos a comenzar con lo más obvio y no
por eso lo menos importante que es la
violación de la tregua olímpica conocida
como la de cacheira en los juegos de la
antigüedad el pacto para realizar
cualquier conflicto bélico durante el
tiempo de los juegos olímpicos el comité
olímpico internacional emitió un
comunicado condenando al quebrantamiento
por parte de rusia de esa tregua que se
acordó en consenso con naciones unidas y
rige desde hace desde siete días antes
de los juegos de invierno hasta siete
días después de los paralímpicos
omar ya existen antecedentes de esta
violación de este período de la tregua
olímpica en años anteriores si ocurrió
durante la celebración de los juegos
olímpicos de verano de beijing 2008
cuando rusia y georgia entraron en
conflicto por el control de las
repúblicas pro ruso de osetia del sur y
abjazia y esto específicamente que
efectos prácticos puede tener este este
rompimiento de esta ley para esta tregua
de momento el comité paralímpico
internacional ha expresado su
preocupación en torno a la participación
de los atletas ucranianos en los juegos
paralímpicos en los juegos de deporte
adaptado que deben iniciarse el 4 de
marzo pues no se sabe cómo podrán
desplazarse hasta beijing y si están
seguros en este momento por cierto que
aparte del coi se ha pronunciado el
presidente de la fifa gianni infantino
que ha solicitado el cese inmediato de
hostilidades
fifa expreses a este respecto fifa
expresas los deseos de un rápido cese de
hostilidades y de paz en ucrania
en for peace in a new crime fifa con de
maxwell de yuso force my brain ukraine
en y type fifa condena también el uso de
la fuerza por parte de rusia en ucrania
y cualquier tipo de violencia para
resolver los conflictos cualquier tipo
porque la violencia nunca es la solución
así que llamamos a las partes a
restablecer la paz a través de un
diálogo constructivo y por supuesto fifa
expresa su solidaridad con las personas
afectadas por este conflicto
true constructive va a tomar
efectivamente la fifa va a tener que
tomar decisiones
con relación a este a este conflicto
cuáles pueden ser si bueno precisamente
este jueves las federaciones del fútbol
de polonia suecia y república checa-
emitieron un comunicado conjunto en el
que pidieron el cambio de sede de los
partidos eliminatorios al mundial de
qatar que deben jugarse en territorio
ruso argumentando razones de seguridad
para los equipos y los oficiales
delegados recordemos que estos tres
países forman parte de los playoff que
se disputarán entre el 24 y el 29 de
marzo para arrojar un clasificado para
la copa del mundo fifa ha respondido que
monitorea la situación antes de tomar
una decisión
traumar y qué va a pasar con la ciudad
de san petersburgo que es la segunda
ciudad más grande de rusia que es la
sede de la final de la web esa es otra
decisión que está pendiente el estadio
gazprom en sant san petersburgo en el
escenario designado para definir al
campeón de la champions al 28 de mayo
pero son muchas las voces tanto del
mundo del deporte como de la política
que han pedido a la web fue un cambio de
sede que sería el tercero consecutivo-
los otros dos causados por la el
presidente de la uefa el esloveno
alexandr shefer in ha convocado para el
viernes una reunión extraordinaria del
comité ejecutivo para tomar una decisión
tomaré hace unos minutos hablábamos de
sanciones esto como puede entonces
afectar a rusia como impactan al deporte
ruso esta es una actividad que cuenta
con una alta influencia y una alta
inversión de rusia y ya se han comenzado
a verificar consecuencias por ejemplo el
equipo alemán schalke 04 anunció el
retiro del logo de gazprom el gigante
energético ruso de su camiseta en vista
de los acontecimientos además removió de
su junta de directores a matías bar nick
que a su vez es director ejecutivo del
gasoducto nord stream 2 cuya
certificación por parte de alemania ha
quedado pendiente
bueno además consecuencias según nos
dice también para algunos brasileños
algunos deportistas y otras
consecuencias son precisamente las
meramente
humanas en este conflicto como
precisamente la seguridad de los atletas
este juego es circuló un vídeo de
futbolistas brasileños que forman parte
del dínamo y el shakhtar que se han
quedado atrapados junto a sus familias
en kiev y están pidiendo al gobierno de
su país asistencia técnica para salir y
también en el baloncesto se está
viviendo una situación similar de quién
estamos hablando si el barcelona tenía
que viajar a san petesburgo para
disputar partidos de la euroliga contra
el zenit y el cs acá de rusia el equipo
había recibido garantías por parte de la
organización de que iban a poder entrar
y salir sin problemas de rusia pero
finalmente el club canceló el viaje y
otro tanto está haciendo el bayern
munich de basket que también tenía que
jugar contra el cska y pidió al
aplazamiento del partido lo cual fue
aceptado por la europa league ya ha
habido pronunciamientos de gobiernos y
organismos internacionales pero que
dicen de la situación
de ucrania
en las organizaciones deportivas por
ejemplo words lyrics que es la
organización que rige el atletismo
mundial ha emitido un comunicado en el
que condena la invasión militar rusa a
ucrania el ente presidido por sebastián
code anunció que hará seguimiento a la
situación que de momento no amenaza son
mundiales de marcha por equipos y el
mundial bajo techo de belgrado además
recuerda que rusia se encuentra
suspendida del atletismo desde 2015 como
consecuencia del llamado dopaje de
estado además la atp anunció el
aplazamiento del challenger de moscú que
debía jugarse la próxima semana por
preocupación sobre la seguridad de los
jugadores y previendo incertidumbre en
torno a los itinerarios aéreos romario
en cuanto a los organismos deportivos
pero que hay de los deportistas que
dicen ellos de esta situación bueno esta
mañana se pronunciaba en contra de la
guerra y a favor de ucrania el capitán
de la selección rusa en el mundial de
fútbol de 2018 feder tzolov a través de
sus redes sociales luego ha habido
pronunciamientos también del ex campeón
de fórmula uno sebastian vettel que dijo
que no asistirá al gran premio de sochi
en septiembre para mostrar su rechazo a
la invasión rusa ucrania y más
recientemente se le unieron también otro
ex campeón fernando alonso y el actual
monarca max first up en que han dicho
que tampoco correrán en sochi y eso ha
obligado a la fia a plantearse una sede
alterna que podría ser turquía por mares
a muchas gracias por habernos acompañado
en el programa de habernos dado este
análisis desde la perspectiva deportiva
muchas gracias por habernos acompañado